let's return to the budget now
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt will set out his
tax and spending plans for the years
ahead later on this morning with a focus
on growing the economy well with me now
is Justine Greening she's the former
conservative education secretary and
also former economic secretary to the
treasury good to have you here this
morning thank you for coming in despite
the strikes
um a big expansion of child care we're
expecting today could this be a game
changer for the Tories do you think I
think it's certainly going to be a key
Battleground at the next election uh
labor have talked about bringing forward
some ambitious plans I think for parents
most importantly for many this will be a
welcome change there's no doubt that for
a significant number of parents very
young children the cost of child care is
prohibitive I think the real challenge
for Jeremy Hunter's Chancellor is almost
not just this announcement but then
implementing it how is the child care
sector really going to be able to expand
to provide that that extra capacity and
do the numbers make sense for many child
care providers who will say that really
their challenge is that the amount
they're being paid by the government per
hour of child care doesn't really match
the costs of providing it well Lee
because when your education secretary
the government brought in 30 hours for
three and four-year-olds but there was
concern that if it wasn't funded
properly that the costs will be passed
on to those with younger children and
that that happened do you think the
government will get the funding right
this time I certainly hope so and one of
the toughest areas introducing the
policy originally was to work out that
rate for providers because there are so
many different circumstances that
they're in as businesses it's actually
quite hard getting one rate that will
suit all of them in a sense
um but broadly this policy has been a
success I think it has absolutely
supported often working women to get
into work I think this is now the next
stage it was always something I think on
our agenda even introducing the 30-hour
provision that you might want to go down
the age range so I think this is a
welcome step forward implementing it's
not going to be that easy but actually I
think for many parents it would be good
news are they just nicking Labor's
policy though oh come on I think um I
think the public just want to see change
on the ground and actually is that a yes
well I don't think it really matters
as far as the public are concerned no
party's got a monopoly on good ideas and
I think if political competition means
that the good ideas are taken and
implemented then
that's good news for the public you
mentioned women and getting women back
into the workplace it is really crucial
isn't it what what would be the economic
benefit of getting a whole load of of
mums of one and two-year-olds back into
the workplace quickly do you think I
think it's twofold partly it's the
skills Gap that we got and and obviously
the the workforce shortages literally I
think the second thing is
hopefully meaning that parents and
particularly women often who this
affects that are already in work don't
perhaps have career disruption
that they wouldn't now get if they're
able to actually access Child Care
earlier so I think it it probably has a
double benefit for both the economy but
also women being able to to more easily
continue in their careers once they've
started a family which I think in terms
of gender equality is a really positive
step as well you're really passionate
about social Mobility do you looking
ahead at what's trailed in this budget
is there anything in it that you think
that's going to really make a difference
well the one thing I really want to see
is reform of the apprenticeships Levy
it's not just about getting more people
into the workforce it's also about
upskilling reskilling and allowing more
people access to opportunity
particularly younger people and I think
we all know how tough covert has been
for many people in the education system
so I think a a sensible set of reforms
apprenticeship Levy would not only allow
great employers that want to spend more
of that Levy re-skilling and upskilling
people to be able to do that I also
think it would provide a lot more
opportunities for young people and in
the end Jeremy Hunt I think is quite
right to say this needs to be a budget
for growth that's what's being trailed
but the one thing that really Turbo
Charge growth in the UK is actually
improving social mobility and making
access to opportunity fairer in the
future than it's been in the past and
that is fundamentally about a talent a
skills agenda and that's what I really
hope we hear a lot more about today as
well what about public sector pay
obviously today is happening against the
backdrop of all these strikes the
possibility the public sector pay
increases could go up to around 5.5
percent within potentially in the budget
would that be enough do you think to
Stave off strikes well it's it doesn't
look like it at the moment obviously the
pay review body will look at almost the
market economics of this and I think at
some stage an agreement is going to have
to be reached by the government but when
you look at some of those key shortages
we've got in the public sector whether
it's teachers whether it's information
whether it's in the NHS actually again
you look at people who have left the
workforce perhaps slightly older I think
we need to change our mindset on the
fact that people come into careers and
move up actually people can reskill and
retrain even well into their 40s and 50s
and have successful long careers in some
of these key roles that are really
important for wider Society and also
potentially increasing the amount that
they could put into their pensions do
you think that will really encourage
people people like doctors perhaps who
might have retired early to come back to
work all the evidence seems to suggest
so and it just seems a sensible step to
me to make it easier for people who want
to keep working to do that and of course
post covered with more hybrid is working
actually this old-fashioned sense of
retirement that one day you're working
five days a week the next day you're
retired and you're doing no work I think
we all can see that as employers bring
in generally more flexible work
practices there is a real opportunity
for people to keep active keep working
but also do a better stronger job of
providing for themselves once they get
into older age we're also not expecting
tax cuts for personal taxes a proposed
increase in corporation tax we think is
still going to go ahead
um do you how do you think a lot of
conservative back benches will feel
about that do you think that enough else
will be offered for Jeremy Hunt to
square the sort of Circle of discontent
I think this is perhaps the most
challenging issue for Jeremy Hunt
um he's got this really tough tough call
hasn't he
um whose fault is that his now boss
Rishi sunak actually introduced it as
Chancellor and many of the people who
are now saying this is a terrible rise
we're part of Boris Johnson's government
uh that introduced it so I think the
substance of it in practice for growth
is that
I get that um
corporation tax is going up I I think
the plan is that you'll backfill that
tax take with incentives for investment
for
um for companies and so make it more
targeted to drive growth but actually in
a knowledge economy a lot of that growth
needs to come from upskilling reskilling
and talent and so actually the danger I
think for Jeremy Hunters he puts it all
into incentives for gov for companies to
invest in things technology but there
aren't the incentives there as well for
uh companies to invest in people and
actually that to my mind means you need
a more measured uh change of the
corporation tax because often it's it's
increasing tax that just literally means
the company looks as its wage Bill and
thinks well I can't I can't grow the
staff that I need so to pushing it up to
25 you don't think is necessarily the
best idea I think there needs to be a
balance and there's one area that I do
think Jeremy Hunt needs to think very
carefully about and that is for these
mid-sized companies so the headline rate
is going up to 25 for companies with
profits over a quarter of a million the
19 rate we've currently got remains for
companies with profits 50 000 or less
but for those actually quite small
companies earning 50 000 to a quarter of
a million profits they now have a rate
of 26 and a half percent
and so if you think these are the
fledgling potential Growth Company
companies that are going to really drive
the economy in the coming years I think
we really need to look at making sure
those businesses are supported because
going from a rate of 19 to 26.5 is a
huge rise for them to Bear okay Jesse
Greene good to see you thanks very much
for coming in thank you